- I did see that you betrayed me and John.
I hear that you are Team Ariana.
- I am. (laughs)
- Which is totally fine.
I used to rub it in John's face,
'cause you were like
Team Kelly for a minute.
- I know.
- Then Ariana comes in. Here's
the thing, I can't blame you,
because my daughter's in love with her.
(Chrissy laughing)
So, I do nothing cool.
Like, River found out I was
gonna be on a show with Arianna.
- I love River so much.
She's the kindest, sweetest, little girl.
- Well, yes, most of the time.
(both laughing)
But my kid love, she loves her,
so she's so excited about her.
- Yeah, she's
It's so funny, Ariana's demographic is so,
it's like two years old,
'cause Luna was into her when she was two.
- Yeah.
- To, I mean-
- She's Luna's favorite though, right?
'Cause John always talks about it.
- In the car is all Ariana,
a lot of Dua Lipa now,
but it's always gonna be all about Ariana.
And so, yeah, I sent that assets thing
and everyone's like, "What are assets?"
And I was like, "Oh, it's
like a Hollywood thing,"
I think-
(Kelly laughing)
You know, like-
- How can I post and help?
Why are you trying to help
freaking Ariana Grande?
You don't think that we need help?
She's fricking Ariana-
- That's what I said.
- [Kelly] She's got like
a billion followers.
- I know, so now I'm like, I don't know,
I'm like, I think I've
got to throw John a bone
because he's so clearly going to lose.
- Yeah, forget John.
- Forget John.
- I know.
- I'm like, help me.
- I mean, he's going to
have people voting that -
- Your husband is a freaking EGOT winner
and she's freakin' Ariana
Grande, you help me.
- Okay, actually I like that!
- I'm just kidding, no.
- I could do that.
- I'm just kidding.
- You're right.
I'm just kidding no,
help Ariana, cause I like
- You're right, John
doesn't need anything else.
Honestly, if you don't -
- John doesn't need anything
else to rub in my face, okay.
- I don't care who wins
as long as you guys are
on the show forever,
so we can have dinner parties.
- As long as
Yes, our teams and our
coach sitters, I love that.
- [Chrissy] Yes
As long as it's not Blake you're helping,
I don't care who it is in all seriousness.
(Chrissy laughs)
- Blake would be so proud of me,
I can't wait to see him next.
- Who cares when he
thinks? Don't back him.